[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه ماي ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
لوكاشينكو يؤكد بدء استقبال بلاده للاسلحه
النوويه من روسيا ويطمئن بوتين بانها
بمامن من هجمات هولنديه محتمله
[موسيقى]
بعد نشره فيديو
يرفع شكوى ضد اردوغان والنحو 50 الف شاب
يبلغون سن التصويت قبل يومين من الجوله
الثانيه للانتخابات
بعد التهديد الاسرائيلي ايران تكشف عن
احدث صواريخها البالسيه يصل مداها الى تل
ابيب
[تصفيق]
بايدن يعيد احياء خطه طوارئ عام 2011 حال
عدم التوصل الاتفاق حول ازمه الدين ومقرث
يلجا لاستشاره ترامب
[موسيقى]
عمليه نقل اسلحه النوويه تكتيكيه من روسيا
الى بيلاروسيا بدات بالفعل وفقا لتاكيدات
الرئيس
اليدكو الذي طمان موسكو بان الاسلحه
النوويه ستكون امنه تماما وبعيده عن ايدي
المحاربين بما في ذلك بولندا وفق قوله هذا
ووقعت موسكو ومنسك على وثائق تحدد اجراءات
الاحتفاظ بالاسلحه النوويه الروسيه غير
الاستراتيجيه في منشاه تخزين خاصه على
اراضي بيلاروسيا اما حلفاء اوكرانيا
الغربيين فاعلنوا استمرار تقديم الدعم وهو
ما اكدته واشنطن ومن بعدها برلين
[موسيقى]
المانيا طبعا لا تمتلك مقاتلات اف 16 ولكن
هذه المقاتلات تجهز باجهزه استشعار وردرات
واسلحه يمكن للحكومه الالمانيه ان تقدم
الكثير هنا على سبيل المثال صواريخ تاوروس
وهي صواريخ كروز موجهه وبعيده المدى وايضا
يمكن لالمانيا تامين دعم لوجستي قوي من
خلال الصيانه والوقود وغيرها الكثير وايضا
في التدريب اعتقد ان هناك استعدادا كبيرا
لدى الحكومه لمساعده اوكرانيا لانها لا
تقدم لنا ايه خدمات بل هي تدافع عن حريتنا
واذا سقطت فلن تكون لدينا فقط مساله
ملايين اللاجئين بل ايضا فان روسيا ستشجع
اخرين على تكرار السيناريو مع ايران في
العراق مثلا والصين مع تايوان مقاتله الاف
16 هي وسيله جيده لتدمير خطوط التعبئه
الجويه الروسيه وحتى مواجهه القوات الجويه
الروسيه جوا
اعلنا حاكم منطقه
الروسيه بان سلطات المقاطعه سجلت 120 قصفا
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه خلال ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه وفي منشور له على تيليجرام اكد
باصابه شخصين من جراء القصر فيما تم
العثور على ذخيره غير منفجره في بلده بلده
كالينين والعمل جارا على ازالتها وفق حاكم
المنطقه
كشفت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن ملامح الهجوم
الذي استهدف الكريم بدايه الشهر الحالي
ونقلت الصحيفه عن مسؤولين امريكيين
ترجيحاتهم بان الاوكرانيين هم من نفذوا
العمليه ومن دون علم الرئيس فلاديمير
فلاديمير في وقت كشفت كياف عن قائمه
اغتيالات لروس على راسهم الرئيس بوتين
في الثالث من ماي الحالي مسيرات تستهدف
قلب الكرملين عمليه تركت اسئله كثيره
مفتوحه
اليوم تكشفت على ما يبدو ملامح عمليه
تشكلت ونفذت دون علم الرئيس الاوكراني
فمن واشنطن المتهمه ايضا من موسكو بالوقوف
وراء العمليه رجح مسؤولون امريكيون ان
الاوكرانيين هم من نفذوا الهجوم وفق صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز
ووفق الصحيفه ايضا فان تقييما اوليا توصلت
اليه الاستخبارات الامريكيه عبر اعتراض
اتصالات يشير الى ان الهجوم دبرته على
الارجح احدى الوحدات العسكريه او
الاستخباراتيه الاوكرانيه الخاصه
هجوم دفع بالمسؤولين الامريكيين الى
الاعتقاد ان زلنسكي لا يوقع على جميع
العمليات السريه كما انه من غير الواضح
اذا ما كان على علم بها قبل تنفيذها
وبحسب الصحيفه يبدو ان الهجوم جزء من
سلسله عمليات سريه ازعجت مسؤولين في
امريكا اكبر مصدر لسلاح الى اوكرانيا
موسكو اكدت ما جاءت به نيويورك تايمز اما
فقد جددت نفيها معتبره ان روسيا تلعب على
مخاوف الغرب لتقليص امدادات الاسلحه
الاكييف
بالتزامن مع ذلك كشفت الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه عن قائمه اهداف لمواطنين الروس
ورئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الهدف رقم
واحد
قائمه اعتبرها الكريم ارهابيه مؤكدا ان
الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه تعرف وظيفتها وما
تفعله لحمايه بوتين
قائمه اهداف لم تخفيها تفتح اسئله كثيره
لعل من بينها ان كان زلينسكي لا يعلم عنها
ايضا
حتى وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان مقاتلاتها
اعترضت محاوله قاذفتين استراتيجيتين
امريكيتين اختراق المجال الجوي الروسي فوق
بحر البلطيق واكدت الدفاع الروسيه بان
مقاتلاتها نفذت طلعاتها بما يتفق بدقه مع
القواعد الدوليه لاستخدام المجال الجوي
الخلاف بين قائد فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه جذوره قديمه وان فضحته الحرب في
اوكرانيا تحديدا لكن جذور هذا الصراع
الحقيقيه تعود لسوريا هذا ما خلص اليه
تقرير لصحيفه
وفي مقطع فيديو كما نتذكر نشره زعيم فاجنر
وقف الرجل محاطا بجثث مقاتله في مخمود
الاوكرانيه وراحه يكيل بالشتائم للقاده
العسكريين واولهم وزير الدفاع
حينها اوحى للكثير من المراقبين بان هناك
صدعا اساسيا بين كل من فاجنر من جهه
والكريم من جهه اخرى وتوقع ان تكون ايام
بريكوجين ربما باتت معدوده خصوصا وان موقف
الاخير لم يقف عند حد انتقاد القاده
العسكريين بل راحه يشيد ايضا بالقوات
الاوكرانيه ويحذر من ان روسيا غير مستعده
لمقاومه الاوكر بل ليس هذا فحسب بل قال
ايضا بانه كان يقاتل البيروقراطيه الروسيه
ايضا وفي تقريرها المطول تقول الصحيفه بان
لدى الروس او لدى الضباط الروس الكثير من
الاسباب لكراهيه فاقنر ومؤسس فاجنر تحديدا
كاتصاله المباشر مع بوتين وكذلك الرواتب
المرتفعه والثقافه الوحشيه للمجموعه لكن
كل هذه الخلافات ما هي الا كالجزء الظاهر
من جبل الثالث حيث تؤكد الصحيفه هنا بان
الصراع بدا في عام 2018 حين شنت فاجنر
هجوما على منطقه دير الزور السوريه تحديدا
حيث يوجد فيها كما هو معلوم حقول حقل
تحديدا حقول نفطيه هناك حيث توجد قوات
امريكيه وتضيف الصحيفه ايضا بما انه بمجرد
ما نفت الدفاع الروسيه العلاقه بفاجنر امر
البنتاغون بضرب فاجنر وفي غضون ساعات قتل
واصيب المئات من مرتزقه فاجنر هذه الحادثه
وصفها مراسل الحربي وكاله الانباء الروسيه
بالخيانه وقال في مذكراته لم نكن نعرف ان
الطائره الوحيده فوقنا كانت امريكيه وبان
رجال الدفاع الجوي كانوا جميعا يختبئون
تحت تنانير الفتيات
[موسيقى]
في تركيا وقبل يومين من بدء التصويت على
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات التركيه رفع
كمال
شكوى ضد منافسها الرئيس التركي اردوغان
بعد بث مقطع فيديو يربط الاول بحزب العمال
الكردستاني مطالبا اياها بنحو 47 الف يورو
كتعويض هذا وكان اردوغان قد بس خلال تجمع
كبير في اسطنبول مقطع فيديو قصير يظهر على
حد قوله كالتشار اوغلو يسير يدا بيد مع
حزب العمال الكردستاني المنظمه التي
تصنفها انقره على انها ارهابيه وبالرغم من
انه اعترف بان الفيديو مفبرك وكرر هنا
الرئيس التركي الاتهام المباشر لخصمه بانه
متحالف مع منظمه حزب العمال الكردستاني
ايضا في الشان التركي اعلنت الاحزاب
المواليه للاكراد في تركيا دعم مرشح
الرئاسه المعارض كمال كلتش في جوله
الاعاده في الانتخابات الرئاسيه دون تسميه
الاخير وقال مسؤولون في حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي وحلفائهم من حزب اليسار الاخضر
انهم يسعون الى التغيير في جوله الاعاده
ولا يقبلون ببقاء اردوغان مشيرين الى انهم
سيصوتون لصالح انهاء نظام الرجل الواحد
[موسيقى]
ليس خيارا لنا ابدا الخيار الوحيد هو
استبداله والسلطه التي يمثلها لذلك نؤكد
مره اخرى انه من المهم للغايه وهي اولويه
بالنسبه لنا الاعتراف بتوقعات ورغبه
الاكراد والشعب والمجتمع التركي ككل من
اجل الديمقراطيه والقانون والعداله
والمساواه والحريه وارادتهم الديمقراطيه
في صناديق الاقتراع
قبل يومين اذا من السباق الرئاسي التركي
الذي سيحسم سيحسم طبعا بالجوله الثانيه
الاتراك ينتظرون بفارغ الصبر يوم الاحد
المقبل لمعرفه من سيحكم البلاد الرئيس
التركي اردوغان ام مجددا طبعا مجددا ام
كمال
مرشح المعارضه ولكن ما هي اليه الجوله
الثانيه وهل تختلف عن الجوله الاولى من
الناحيه التقنيه لا يوجد فرق الا
ان الفرق الوحيد طبعا بالجوله الثانيه انه
لا يشترط حصول المرشح على خمسين زائد واحد
كما في الجوله الاولى والذي ينال اصواتا
اكثر يكسب السباق الرئاسي حتى ولو بفارق
صوت واحد فقط سنضيق الاقتراع مشاهدينا
ستفتح وتفتح يوم الاحد عند الساعه الثامنه
صباحا وستغلق عند الساعه الخامسه مساء
نبدا اعلان النتائج بشكل تدريجي كما في
الجوله الاولى اللافت ايضا في الجوله
الثانيه بان 47 الف شاب وشاب اكمل اسامي
عشر من عمرهم بعد الجوله الاولى التي
كانوا فيها قاصرين وبالتالي حماست هؤلاء
لتصويت للمره الاولى ستدفعهم للاقتراع
ولكن من غير المعروف اين ستصب اصوات
الشباب التركي هنا ايضا يجب التوقف عند
الناخبين الذين لم يصوتوا في الجوله
الاولى وعدد هؤلاء ثمانيه ملايين حيث يعمل
كل من اردوغان
اوغلو للاستماله اصواتهم لان كل صوت سيكون
مؤثر لحسم السباق في الجوله جوله الاعاده
الثانيه في الجوله الثانيه ايضا مشاهدينا
كان لاصوات المغتربين صدى اكبر من الاولى
وبحسب الارقام الاخيره فقد صوت اكثر من
100 الف ناخب جديد عن الرقم الماضي بجولات
الاعاده
الاكراد والخشيه من فوز اردوغان وسط تصاعد
النبره القوميه قبيل جوله الاعاده
الانتخابات التركيه واحتماليه فوز اردوغان
الذي اثار قلقا في صفوف الاكراد خوفا من
تصعيد عسكري الاحزاب المواليه للاكراد
تؤكد دعمها للمعارضه التركيه لكنهم لم
يذكروا بالاسم
النظام الغريب الذي اسسه اردوغان وشركائه
سبب المشاكل المجتمعيه التي نعاني منها ما
سيتم تصويت عليه في 28 من مايو هو مدى
امكانيه استمرار هذا النظام الغريب من
عدمه
تحول في المواقف في سنواته الاولى من
السلطه منح اردوغان المزيد من الحقوق
للاكراد والغى القيود المفروضه على
استخدام اللغه الكرديه عام 2015 وبعد
انهيار وقف اطلاق النار غير اردوغان مساره
السياسي
وشنت السلطات التركيه حمله قمع ادت الى
اعتقال الالاف من الاكراد
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من اسطنبول زيدان
مراسل العربيه زيدان يعني اخر التحديثات
قبل يومين من جوله الاعاده من انضموا الى
الذين يستطيعون الانتخاب لمن سيصوت بحسب
المعلومات الاوليه خصوصا بان اردوغان
استطاع جذب فئه كبيره من هؤلاء
بالانتخابات او من جوله الاولى
مساء الخير ليال ولك ولجميع المشاهدين لا
شك ان
معرفه هويه او الشخص الذي سيصوت له هؤلاء
لا يمكن التنبؤ بها حتى الان لكن ما من
خلال ما تم طرحه او من خلال نتائج التي
شاهدناها في الجوله الاولى تتحدث عن ان
فئه الشباب في الولايات الرئيسيه الكبرى
في ولايات اسطنبول وانقره وازمير وايضا
بعض الولايات الكبرى صوتوا يعني قسم منهم
صوت للمعارضه التركيه طبعا هذا طبعا هذا
التصويت صوتت كل هذه المدن اعطت صوتها
لمرشح المعاضه كمالك لجدار يعني الكثير من
الخبراء يرون ان السبب الرئيسي هو ارتفاع
مستوى او ارتفاع الاسعار وغلاء المعيشه في
هذه المدن اكثر من غيرها في وسط الاناضول
والبحر الاسود وجنوب تركيا حتى في مناطق
الزلزال بينما في تلك المناطق صوتت تلك
الولايات حوالي 51 ولايه ولايه من ضمنهم
طبعا فئه الشباب صوتوا لي الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان هناك الاثار الاقتصاديه
الناجمه الاثار السلبيه الناجمه عن التضخم
الاقتصادي اقل مما هي عليه في الشمال
والمدن الرئيسيه كاسطنبول وانقره طبعا
ازمير محسومه سلفا للمعارضه التركيه وحزب
الشعب الجمهوري تاريخيا هي معقل
العلمانيين الاتراك بالتالي نتحدث عن
اسطنبول وانقى غالبيه فئه الشباب او
غالبيه حتى من هم في فئات اخرى صوتوا لكم
جدار اوغلو نتيجه تضرر هذه الفئات من
الازمه الاقتصاديه كون هذه المدن كما ذكرت
مستوى الغلاء فيها اكبر بكثير من بقيه
المناطق في وسط وجنوب ومناطق البحر الاسود
زيدان بموضوع
المغتربين يعني لافت بان هناك زياده كبيره
بالاعداد بالجوله الاولى كنا نتحدث ان
معظم المغتربين هم يصبون لصالح الرئيس
التركي لانهم ذهبوا بفتره معينه يعني خارج
تركيا اليوم زياده هذا العدد ماذا يعني
وايضا تصويت الكردي بالجوله جوله الاعاده
كيف ستكون خارطه
نعم ليال لا شك ان الانطباع الاول بعد
نهايه الجوله الاولى كانت الجميع يقول ان
الجوله الثانيه لن تشهد اقبالا كبيرا كون
النتيجه تقريبا قد حسمت للرئيس التركي بعد
تقدمه بعده نقاط على بحاجه الى نصف نقطه
مئويه فقط حتى يحسم الانتخابات من الجوله
الاولى اضف الى ذلك موضوع ان الرئيس
التركي والتحالف الذي يقوده هو تحالف
الشعب سيطر على البرلمان او اخذ اغلبيه في
البرلمان بالتالي كانت الامور شبه محسومه
او الانطباع الاول ان الامور محسومه لصالح
رئيس تركي بالتالي كان هناك تكهنات بان
الاقبال على الانتخابات او الجوله الثانيه
لن يكون كبيرا لكن ما جاءت به النتائج
والاخبار من الاتراك المغتربين في الخارج
يعني تطحض هذه التكهنات وتمبا ان الاقبال
على الجوله الثانيه ربما يكون كبير بشكل
كبير بالتالي نشهد رقم قياسي تجاوز يعني
قبل ان اكون معكم على الهواء قرات الاخبار
مليون و900 الف ناخب صوتوا في الخارج وفي
المعابر الحدوديه والمطارات وهذا اكبر رقم
في تاريخ الجمهوريه من حيث عدد نسبه
التصويت في الخارج
وبالتالي نتوقع ان يكون يوم الاحد ايضا
يشهد اقبالا كبيرا
كاقبال الذي شهدته صناديق الاختراع في
الجوله الاولى قبل حوالي اسبوعين بالنسبه
الى الصوت الكردي نعم كان هناك اسئله
واسئله واستفسارات كثيره لمن ستتجه الكتله
الكرديه هل ستصوت لكلجدار اوغلو مره ثانيه
كما صوتت له في الجوله الاولى لكن هذه
المره هناك معطى جديد كالجدار
تحالف مع احد اكثر
المتطرفين واكحد اكثر الاشخاص الذين
يعادون اولا اللاجئين السوريين والمهاجرين
بشكل عام وايضا حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي وما
يسميه الجناح السياسي لحزب العمال
كردستاني وانا اتحدث هنا عن اوميت اوزداغ
رئيس حزب النصر وبالتالي هناك سؤال هل
ستستجيب الكتله الكرديه المؤيده لحزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الذي دعا للتصويت نعم
لم يسمي هذا لم يسميك الجدار بالاسم بناء
على توصيه من جدار اوغلو الذي طلب من حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي والسياسيين اكراد عدم
دعمه بشكل علني خوفا من خساره الاصوات
القوميه مجددا في جوله الاعاده لكن
الرساله واضحه ومفهومه هنا السؤال وهنا
الكتله الكرديه امام استحقاق هل ستستجيب
لطلب حزبها مره ثانيه والتصويت رغم انك
جدار اوغلو اتحالف مع عدوهم كما يصفون ام
ان الكتله ربما تتخذ قرار اخر شكرا على كل
حال سنبقى نتابع معك يعني كنت تطورات
الملف الانتخابي التركي في الايام
والساعات المقبله شكرا لك
التاسعه مستمره والتهاب بعد قليل
على واقع اشتباكات متقطعه طرف الصراع في
السودان يتهمان بعضهما بخرق اتفاق الهدنه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد يومين فقط من اثاره
رئيس الاركان الاسرائيليه لاحتمال تحرك ضد
ايران بسبب برنامجها النووي طهران تكشف
النقاب عن اقوى صواريخها البالسيه ويصل
يصل مدى هذا الصاروخ الى الفيكومتر لا
يمكن رصده او اعتراضه لكن وان لم تقل انه
تهديد لاسرائيل لكن الالفي كيلومتر مدى
الصاروخ هي المسافه من ايران الى عمق
اسرائيل الصاروخ البالست الايراني كما
نشاهده هنا خرم شهر تحت اسم خيبر يمتلك
راسا حربيا وزنه 1500 كيلو جرام هذه
الرساله مشاهدينا موجهه للعدو يقول هنا
وزير الدفاع الايراني محمد رضا الشتياني
كي يعلم بان بلاده ستدافع عن نفسها
وانجازاتها لاسيما النوويه منها البرنامج
الصاروخ الايراني وتحديدا البالست طورته
طهران على مر سنوات الماضيه والاسلحه هنا
اي اسلحه طهران قادره على الوصول الى
اسرائيل والقواعد الامريكيه في المنطقه
وفق بياناتها رغم طبعا معارضه الولايات
المتحده وقلق الدول الاوروبيه التي تعثرت
كافه جهودها منذ سبتمبر الماضي لاحياء
اتفاق طهران النووي المبرم عام 2015
الصاروخ خيبر الارادي بالصين من جيل خرم
شهر 4 يصل مداه الى 2000 كيلومتر يمتلك
راسا حربيا وزنه 1500 كيلو جرام عند اصابه
الهدف يعطل الانظمه الدفاعيه المضاده لذا
لا يمكن رصده واعتراضه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من طهران عبر سكايب
محمد صالح صادقيان المحلل السياسي استاذ
محمد يعني ما يعرف باختبارات الردع
الايرانيه ان كان عبر الصواريخ الباليستيه
وان كان عبر الجبهه الشماليه في سوريا وفي
لبنان اليوم كل هذه الاختبارات لن تذهب
الى حرب شامله ومفتوحه وبالتالي اين مداها
وعند اي خط احمر تقف
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين ان يعتقد بان
هناك مواجهه مفتوحه بين ايران واسرائيل
ليس منذ الان ربما منذ سنوات وبالتالي هذه
المنظومه
الصاروخيه التي تمتلكها ايران والتي تقولي
ايران بشكل واضح بان هذه المنظومه هي
مخصصه لاسرائيل لضرب اسرائيل ولمهاجمه
فيما اذا تعرضت ايران لاي هجوم او اعتداد
او اعتداء من قبل اسرائيل او من قبل
الولايات المتحده وبالتالي نحن سمعنا قبل
يومين كما تفضلتيه هناك تصريح كان في غايه
الاهميه وفي غايه الخطوره ايضا عندما قال
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون بان هناك مفاجاه
وعندما يتحدث مفاجاه ضد ايران وعندما
يتحدث الاسرائيليون بهذا بهذا بهذه اللغه
وبهذا السلوك بالتاكيد الايرانيون لن
يقفوا مكتو فيها الايدي
ولافت بان منذ يومين لحد الان لم نسمع اي
رد فعل سواء كان من الخارجي الايرانيه ومن
الحرس الثوري ومن الجيش الايراني لكن
اليوم كان هناك
رد فعل عندما
يعني عرضت ايران هذا الصاروخ صاروخ خيبر
الذي هو مداها الفينكم وقالت بانه لا يمكن
من قبل القبه الحديديه لم تشير الى
اسرائيل لكن بالتاكيد هو كان يشير بشكل
واضح الى التهديدات التي اطلقها وزير وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
وبالتالي انا اعتقد بانها تدخل في اطار
هذه
المواجهه الموجوده بين ايران وبين اسرائيل
محمد ابقى معي لو سمحت ساعود اليك هنا
ايضا مشاهدينا دانت وزاره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه اختبار ايران لصاروخ باليسي بعيد
المدى معتبره انه انتهاك لقرارات مجلس
الامن وايضا بانه يثير القلق في ضوء
التوسع المتواصل للبرنامج النووي الايراني
ياتي هذا بعد اعلان الجانب الايراني اجراء
تجارب اطلاق صاروخ باليستي بنجاح
اعود اليك استاذ محمد استاذ محمد يعني من
المعلوم بان خطوه يعني الخطوه الاسرائيليه
بضرب المنشات النوويه كان هناك تردد فيها
لان الجانب الامريكي لم يغطيها بالفتره
الماضيه وهو كان ذهب اكثر نحو خيار
الاتفاق مع طهران ونحو الخيار الدبلوماسي
اليوم بالايام الماضيه اصبحنا يعني
نلمس كان هناك تغير بالموقف الامريكي عبر
بعض التسريبات هل هذه التسريبات التي دفعت
بالجانب الايراني الى اعاده تثبيت سياسه
الردع بانه فعال غيرتهم نحن ذاهبين نحو
مواجهه كامله
هذا صحيح يعني نحن سمعنا من
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي قال قبل مده
قال بانه ربما يضطر او تضطر الولايات
المتحده الى ان تعطي الضوء الا اخضر
لاسرائيل بمهاجمه البرنامج النووي
الايراني انا اعتقد بان هذا هو تصعيد غير
مبرر لا من قبل الولايات المتحده ولا من
قبل الكيان الاسرائيلي المشكله الان مشكله
عدم حكمه الجانب الامريكي في التعاطي مع
البرنامج النووي الايراني وعندما اقول عدم
الحكمه لان الرئيس ترامب عندما انسحب من
الاتفاق النووي
انسحب من من الاتفاق الذي كان
يضع التخصيب النووي الايراني في اطار
ثلاثه بوينت سته سبعه وهي نسبه قليله جدا
ومنخفضه الان عندما انسحب انسحب الرئيس
ترامب ولحد الانسحاب الامريكي من الاتفاق
النووي ولم تعد الولايات المتحده الى هذا
الاتفاق ولم ترضى بالعوده الى الاتفاق الا
بشروط رفضتها ايران معنى ذلك بان ايران
استطاعت ان تخصب العشرين بالمئه
وهذا هو هذه هي المشكله المشكله ليست
ايران المشكله الولايات المتحده التي
انسحبت من الاتفاق النووي وبالتالي انا
اعتقد بان حل هذه المشكله ليس بالتصعيد
ليس بالتوتر ليس بخلق ازمات جديده وحروب
جديده في المنطقه وانما من خلال الحكمه
التي تستطيع ان تعود لاتفاق
يخصب اليورانيوم بنسبه
3.67 وهذا هذه النسبه لا تقلق الغرب ولا
تقلق الولايات المتحده وهي نسبه بهذا
الموضوع هناك وجهه نظر مختلفه لدى الغرب
ولدي الاسرائيلي بانكم تخطيتم وبانكم
اصبحتم بمرحله متقدمه جدا وبانكم لم
تعودوا مهتمين حتى بموضوع الاتفاق لان
كلفه اكثر مما هو يعني
يضر بارباح اليوم على طهران شكرا لك استاذ
محمد صالح صادقان المحلل السياسي حدثتنا
من طهرا ينضم الينا ايضا مشاهدينا من تل
ابيب عبر زوم
افيتار الون افيتار المستشار الامني
السابق في وزاره الدفاع استاذ الون سمعت
يعني وجهه النظر
الفائده اليوم في طهران حول موضوع تثبيت
سياسات الرجعه الايرانيه تجاه ايضا تثبيت
سياسات الرد على الاسرائيليه كيف تقرا هذا
الموضوع
مساء الخير انا شايف بشكل شخصي وكمان
بعتمد على معلومات انه
المنوعيه او التمرين اللي يغني هو كان جزء
من
السياسه سياسه الايرانيه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل
صفحه جديده في الكتاب في الكتاب السياسي
او
عسكري كتبنا
كتبت قبل اسرائيل اديني نحن سمعنا هلا
وشفنا بالنسبه
لهذا الصاروخ انه بده تعود على اسرائيل
هذا كان
المسؤولين الاسرائيلين اللبنيين رئيس
الاستخبارات قبل يومين
في في تل ابيب وايران بهذه
التهديد الايراني الجديد على اسرائيل
بالنسبه
للخطاب رئيس الاركاني
منوعات النوويه
بموضوع المناورات استاذ يعني هناك ايضا
وجهه نظر اليوم خصوصا من جانب الجانب
الايراني بان قلق اسرائيل ليس محصور فقط
بالاتفاق بالنوه وانما ايضا بتغير مقاربه
ميليشيات يعني ايراننا بالمنطقه من منطق
دعم الداخل الفلسطيني في حال الذهاب الى
مواجهه هل هذا الامر هو الذي يقلق اليوم
ايضا اسرائيل
مهم جدا على فكره هذا هو جديد نحن قبل
ثلاثه اشهر شفنا صاروخ مشابه الى هذه
السموح وهذا بس منوره يغنيها اديني نحن
شايفين في وقت الاخير وفي الفتره الاخيره
سياسه جديده من ناحيه ايران من ناحيه او
باسل الى تسهيل تسعيد في المنطقه مش بس
مع هلا تتحرك كمان
اللي جناحات
امكانيه تبعها زي
حزب الله
الاسلامي وزي حماس اليوم
التهديد من ناحيه اسرائيليه هو زيت شبكه
ايران هي رئيسه الشبكه
والمحدات تحت هذه الغ
ريسه وفي في المنام
توحيد المناطق مع بعض
ما دفع عن ضوء اخضر امريكي لضربه نوويه
على ايران انما تل ابيب ترددت هل هذه
النقطه التي دفعتها الى التردد
باختصار لو سمحت
جديده جوهريه
في مصيره
امريكانيه كمان
تنسيق متبادل وشغل مجتمعات وتعاون بين
اسرائيل وبين غانم بالنسبه عفوا امريكا
بالنسبه لايراني اسرائيل انا ما بفكر انه
تشتغل او تعمل عمليات عسكريه في الوقت
الغاهن وكمان في المستقبل الكريم لحالها
انا مو شايفها
بس اديني التنسيق بين اسرائيل وامريكا هو
التزام اسرائيل وايجابيات اسرائيليه كمان
مش بس لحالها نحن نحكي على سيناريو مختلف
وبالتالي عدنا الى ان الهاجز الاساسي
اليوم هو موضوع الجبهه الشماليه وليس فقط
الموضوع النووي شكرا لك استاذ الونا
افيتارا المستشار الامني السابق في وزاره
الدفاع على هذه المداخله
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اسقاط مسيره صغيره
اجتازت الحدود من لبنان وقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي في بيان ان المسيره تم اسقاطها
بعد تعقبها وانه سيواصل العمل من اجل
التصدي الانتهاك سياده اسرائيل كما جاء في
البيان
[موسيقى]
والى السودان حيث افيد بان هناك اشتباكات
متفرقه تتواصل بين الجيش السوداني من جهه
وقوه الدعم السريع ما ادى الى اختراق
الهدود الهدوء النسبي للهدنه الموقعه بين
طرفي النزاع وافاد شهود عيان بان اشتباكات
بين طرفي النزاع اندلعت امس في الخرطوم
ومدن اخرى حيث اتهم الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع بعضهما البعض بخرق الاتفاق يشار
الى انه تم الاتفاق على وقف اطلاق النار
يوم السبت بعد محادثات في جده بواسطه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده هذا هو فشلت
اعلنت وقف اطلاق النار السابقه في وقف
القتال
هذا ويواجه مشاهدينا الالاف من مصابين
الامراض المزمنه على راسها الاورام
السرطانيه صعوبات في الحصول على جرعات
العلاج المقرره لهم فبعد خروج نسبه كبيره
من المراكز والمستشفيات العلاجيه في
الخرطوم بسبب الحرب توجه كثير من المرضى
نحو شرقي السودان استكمال لعلاجهم غير ان
المراكز العلاجيه في مدينه بورسودان تمر
ايضا بمشكلات كثيره فلنطلع عليها
لاشهر وعرفات تداوم على اخذ جرعاتها
الدوائيه بمركز علاج الاورام السرطانيه
بمدينه بورسودان في ظروف الحرب تمثل جرعه
الدواء هذه نافذه امل لعرفه
من على بعد تطمئن الاهل بحصولها على
جرعتها العلاجيه لكنها تتخوف من تضاؤل فرص
علاجها وندره الدواء بسبب تداعيات الحرب
عملت
العلاج ده يعني
بطالب العلاج استقبل المركز خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه
2700 مريض نسبه كبيره منهم وصلت من عاصمه
البلاد الضغط على المركز يفوق طاقته
الاستيعابيه وفوق كل هذا يحذر مسؤولون من
تبعات وخطوره نفاذ بعض الادويه المهمه
داخل المركز حوالي 3 اسابيع نحن فتحنا
67 ملف ده المريض من خارج الولايه
بيستخدموا نفس حصه الدواء اللي كان بتيجي
لمريض الولايه حاليا في ادويه بدات يعني
تنفذ الكميه بتاعتها تدريجيا حسب
استهلاكها العلاج الهرموني
وقف تماما جزء من العلاج الكيميائي وقف
برضه جزء من الادويه الموجهه
انهيار جزء كبير من البنى التحتيه للقطاع
الصحي في الخرطوم جعل المستشفيات في
بورسودان امام تحديات توفير العلاج لمئات
المرضى القادمين من العاصمه كما يفرض هذا
الواقع مسؤوليه اخرى على السلطات الرسميه
لتامين الدواء
ولمعالجه الموقف بدء التحرك لتوفير ما
يلزم من ادويه لمقابله الاحتياجات الصحيه
الملحه نحو الف طن من المساعدات الانسانيه
وصلت بورسودان خلال الايام الماضيه غير ان
الموقف الدوائي يستدعي تحركا لضمان وصول
الادويه للمراكز العلاجيه بصوره عاجله
دفعنا الحاويه بتاعتنا لكل الدول الشارقه
من الامراض المزمنه خاصه في غسيل الكلى
والاورام وحتى في امراض السكري والضغط
الانسولين وكذا ما شابه ياتي اتباعا زي ما
انا قلت في زيت 952 طن وهنا برضو من امضاء
الطبيه اللجنه بتعمل صباحا ومساء في توزيع
الامداد الدوائي لكل الولايات ومع استمرار
الاشتباكات المسلحه وموجات النزوح فان
الوضع الصحي يواجه مخاطر حقيقيه وهي مخاطر
قد تهدد حياه الاف المرضى في البلاد
نزار البداوي العربيه بورتسودان
[موسيقى]
زينب في المدينه اللزاويه للقصف بطيران
حربي مسير مخلفه اصابات في صفوف المدنيين
واتهم عضو مجلس النواب عن مدينه الزاويه
علي ابو زريبه في تصريحات للحدث الطيران
التركي بقصف المواقع للفصائل الرافضه
للوجود التركي معتبره ذلك بدايه الحرب بين
القوات التركيه الموجوده في ليبيا ضد
القوه الوطنيه الليبيه
[موسيقى]
تتابعنا في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
الصدام سياره ببوابه مقر رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني في لندن والشرطه تعتقل شخصا
وتحقق في الحادث
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد خطه طوارئ تعود لعام
2011 هي خطوه اداره جو بايدن التاليه
والاحتياطيه في حال فشل المفاوضات مع
الجمهوريين حول ازمه الدين العام الامريكي
وفقا طبعا لصحيفه
وهو ما قد يعتبر ورقه ضغط على الجمهوريين
خطه الطوارئ هذه اللجا اليها انذاك باراك
اوباما لمواجهه حد الاقتراض لعام ام الطرف
الاخر المتمثل او العام متمثل بمجلس
النواب الامريكي كاظم مقارصي فلجا الى
دونالد ترامب للاستشارته حول ازمه سقف
الدين دون ان يكشف عن نتائج تلك المشهوره
حتى الان بينما رد الديمقراطيون بان
الجمهوريين يستخدمون الاقتصاد كراهينا
كانت لدي محادثات عده مثمره مع الرئيس
مجلس النواب كيف المقافي وطلبت منه
استمرار المباحثات التي تحرز تقدمها واؤكد
ان التخلف عن سداد الدين ليس خيارا مطروحا
الشعب الامريكي يستحق ان يعلم ان مدفوعات
الخدمات الاجتماعيه ستستمر وان المستشفيات
ستظل مفتوحه وسنواصل التقدم الاقتصادي
الذي حققناه التخلف عن سداد الدين سيضع كل
هذا في خطر اعضاء الكونغرس يدركون كل ذلك
وهم متفقون على انه لا يكون هناك تخلف عن
سداد الدين
تداعيات تاخر التوصل الى حل ازمه سقف
الدين العام في الولايات المتحده يبدو
انها بدات مبكرا قبل قضاء المهله المحدده
بعد اكثر من شهر من الان ومعها ترتفع
المخاوف من تاثر الاقتصاد العالمي العد
العكسي بدا مشاهدينا ماذا لو تخلفت
الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها لاول مره
في تاريخها وهل يهتز هنا النظام المالي
العالمي بعدما وضعت وكاله فتش للتصنيف
الائتمانيه الولايات المتحده تحت المراقبه
ولمنع هذا الامر يتعين على الكونجرس
الامريكيه ان يرفع في اسرع وقت ممكن سقف
الدين العام او ان يعلق العمل به لتجنب
وقوع الولايات المتحده بالكارثه وفق
الخبراء الماليين وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
واظبت على اصدار تصريحات متكرره تقول فيها
بان الولايات المتحده قد تتخلف عن سداد
الديون اعتبارا من يونيون المقبل وفي حال
تخلفت الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها قد
يؤدي ذلك الى تسريح الملايين من الموظفين
عن عملهم في البلاد طبعا كما قد يؤدي الى
وضع حد مؤقت لعمليه استرداد الضرائب
والضمان الاجتماعي والرعايه الطبيه هذا
مشاهدينا على الصعيد المحلي اما على
الصعيد العالمي فيرى هنا المراقبون بان
هناك مخاوف كثيره من اهتزاز ثقه المقرضين
وتراجع مكانه الدولار كعمله احتياطيه
ويمكن ان يكون لفقدان الثقه بالدولار
تداعيات بعيده المدى على الاقتصاد
والسياسه الخارجيه ايضا لان الدول الاخرى
وتحديدا هنا الصين وروسيا
ستستخدمان التخلف الامريكي عن السداد لدفع
عملتهما الخاصه لتصبح بمثابه اساس التجاره
العالميه مستقبلا طبعا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه تفاصيل الموضوع الامريكي ينضم
الينا منه واشنطن مراسل العربيه
بالساعات الماضيه وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
تتحدث عن قرب التوصل الى اتفاق الى اي مدى
هذه الانباء يعني دقيقه وهذا الاتفاق الى
ماذا يعني سيضم ضمن بنوده
الطرفان اي الرئيس الامريكي ومكارتي
يتحدثان عن تحقيق تقدم الرئيس الامريكي
اعطى تفاصيل اكثر حول ما يريد وما لا يريد
فقال قبل قليل في البيت الابيض انه طرح
تجميد الصرف لمده عامين على مستويات لم
يحددها ان كانت العام 2023 او الفين وهذا
امر مهم الامر الثاني انه طرح خفضا في
الانفاق يصل الى تريليون دولار هذه
التفاصيل التي ادلى بها الرئيس بايدن من
الواضح ان الجمهوريين يريدون خصوصا مكارثي
يريدون تجويد الانفاق يريدون خفض
الميزانيه وهذا امر ممكن ولكن اين تخفض
هذه الميزانيه الغلاف ما زال كبيره بين
الطرفين وهم يتابعون هذه المفاوضات على
امل ان يصلوا الى نتيجه بنهار غد
ايضا يعني من ضمن ما ينشر وما يس بب
بالساعات الماضيه بان الفارق بين الطرفين
70 مليون دولار نحن نتحدث عن خفض
كما تحدثت يعني واحد بليون دولار هذه
السبعين الى اين سيتم خفض باي مجالات داخل
الموازنه الامريكيه
التسريبات من قبل البيت الابيض تتهم
الجمهوريين بانه يريدونها وضع بعض
التخفيضات على المدفوعات التي تصل الى
العاطلين او قدامى المحاربين وغيرهم وهذا
ما يروج الديمقراطيون والبيت الابيض الى
انهم يرفضونه بالنسبه
للجمهوريين يعتبرون ان هناك الكثير من
الاعانات التي تقدمها الحكومه الامريكيه
للعاطلين عن العمل وغيرهم وهي تريد خفضا
والتزاما اكثر بتقديم فرص عمل لهؤلاء
الاشخاص بالاضافه الى ذلك يريدون تحريرا
اكثر لقطاع الطاقه والنفط في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا اعتقد ان الرقم 70
مليون
رقم دقيق جدا ولكن هناك مفاوضات
يعني نحن نتحدث عن رقم كبير جدا والاقتصاد
الامريكي يعني كما الاقتصاد العالمي ايضا
يمر بمرحله دقيقه بعد كل يعني رفع الفائده
بالفترات الماضيه وتاثيراتها على الاقتصاد
وبالتالي ايضا هم على مداخل انتخابات وحرب
سياسيه السياسه اليوم كيف ستلعب دور كبير
بهذا الكباش الحاصل بين الطرفين خصوصا
اننا نتحدث عن رقم كبير جدا لتخفيضه
بالنفقات ورفض طرف لزياده الضرائب على
المواطنين الامريكيين
اعتقد ان العنصر الاهم في الحياه السياسيه
للاشهر المقبله هو على الشكل التالي هناك
عدم رضا لدى الشارع الامريكي على اداء
الرئيس بايدن خصوصا في موضوع الاقتصاد
ويتهمونه بانه لا يعالج مساله الغلاء في
الحياه السياسيه والاقتصاديه بالنسبه
للامريكيين الجمهوريون يريدون استغلال هذا
الموضوع هالموضوع ويتهمون الرئيس بايدن
بانه لا يؤدي عملا جيدا وان السبب الاساسي
هو المدفوعات الكبيره الموجوده لدى هذه
الاداره الديمقراطيه اما الرئيس بايدن فهو
يريد من طريق اخر مع الديمقراطيين خصوصا
الليبراليين في الحزب الديمقراطي يقولون
انهم الطرف الذي بالفعل هم الذين يهتمون
بالعاطلين وبالاشخاص الذين يحتاجون الى
المال وبالتالي هناك طرف يريد ان يجذب
الذين يهتمون بسوق العمل وهناك طلب اخر
الذين يهتمون بالعداله الاجتماعيه حين
يصلون بعد عام ونصف هناك مسافه طويله شكرا
لك
نبقى في الولايات المتحده ايضا حيث اصدرت
محكمه امريكيه حكما بالسجن لمده اربع
سنوات ونصف بحق ريتشارد بارنيت الذي وضع
في مطلع 2021 او وضع قدمه على مكتب رئيسه
مجلس النواب في حينها
عندما اقتحم مع حشد بن اصاله الرئيس يومها
مبدا الكابيتال وبحسب اللائحه الاتيه التي
وجهت له ترك الرجل يومها رساله تنطوي على
اهانات لها وسرق ظرفا يحمل توقيعها
[موسيقى]
ردت اعتقلت الشرطه رجلا بعد الصدام سيارته
بوابه مقر رئيس الوزراء البريطاني بوسط
لندن حسبما اعلنت الشرطه هناك وقالت
الشرطه في بيان انه قرابه الساعه الثالثه
وعشرين دقيقه بتوقيت غرينتش اصطدمات سياره
بيبا بوابات داونز في وايت هول وقام افراد
من الشرطه باعتقال الرجل في مكان الحادث
تحت شبهه اضرار جرميه وقياده متهوره
كشف رئيس الوزراء الارميني بان ارمينيا
واذربيجانه فقط على الاعتراف بوحده اراضي
بعضهما بعضا وانهما في طريق الماء الى
تطبيع العلاقات معتبرا ان ذلك سيحقق تقدما
نحو تسويه العلاقات بينهما واتمنى ان يبدا
حوار بناء بين عاصمه اقليم قرباخ وباكو
قريبا مشيرا الى ان بلاده مستعده لفتح
اتصالات في جنوب القوقاز
[موسيقى]
المدارس في افغانستان تتحول الى مراكز
للتطرف هذا اخر ما كشفته صحيفه
في افغانستان سبعه ملايين ونصف المليون
طالب يواجهون خطر فقدان المهارات تحت سطوه
فكر طالبان على المناهج التعليميه
طريق صباحي معتاد يوم دراسي وزملاء صفه
على حاله لم يستطع التمييز ان ثمه تحولا
طالزيه المدرسي وابعد
طلاب كابول مدارس البنين في افغانستان
تحولت تدريجيا الى مراكز للتطرف والارهاب
وفق مجله الفرن بوليسي
مدارس التعليم وان تبدلت اشكالها اختصرت
اغلبها على هذا طلاب منكبون على الهجاء
منهم من وجد لنفسه طموحا هنا القران ناتي
هنا بشغف وحماس للدراسه ولان نصبح في
المستقبل اشخاصا حافظين للدين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خاف لا يشي بتفاؤل براي متابعين اطفال
اختصر تعليمهم على منهجا بفكر طالبان
مدارس طالبان مصانع تديم الجهل وتحرض على
الكراهيه لانتاج ارهابيين اما على اطراف
افغانستان تلقين لا سقف له فكر امتدا الى
هنا ايضا مدارس على بساطتها كانت اول
المطبقين لمفاهيم طالبا
طالبا تريد اعاده تعريف المفاهيم مثل
الحريه وحقوق الانسان والسلام والمساواه
بحسب تفسيرهم الخاص للتعاليم اذا قضى طلاب
بقدرات محدوده قراءه وكتابه لا اكثر سبعه
ملايين ونصف المليون طالب في اخر احصائيه
يعرضهم ضيق الافق اما للتطرف او لمستقبل
لا صفاء فيه غذاء السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
تسببت الفيضانات التي خلفتها الامطار
الرعديه في الجزائر بوفاه طفله تبلغ من
العمر سبع سنوات عثر عليها في مجرى في
ولايه قالمه شرقيه البلاد
[موسيقى]
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو رجال الاطفاء وهم
يحاولون اخماد حريق مشتعل في مبنى قريب
لمحطه سكك حديد سن المركزيه كما اشتعلت
النيران في سياره كانت متوقفه قرب المكان
[تصفيق]
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
لوكاشينكو يؤكد بدء استقبال بلاده للاسلحه
النوويه من روسيا ويطمئن بوتين بانها
بمامن من هجمات بولنديه محتمله
[موسيقى]
بعد نشره بدايه
ونحو خمسين الف شاب يبلغون سن التصويت قبل
يومين من الجوله الثانيه للانتخابات
بعد تهديد الاسرائيلي ايران تكشف عن احدث
صواريخها البالسيه يصل مداها الى تل ابيب
ايضا يعيد احياء خطه الطوارئ عام 2011
حاله عدم التوصل لاتفاق حول ازمه الدين
الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا
لكن اخبار العربيه مستمره كما كل ليله
والان الى 360 مع الزميله راويه مساء
الخير راويه مساء الخير ليان سنتحدث عن
التداعيات المحتمله للقرار الروسي بنقل
الاسلحه النوويه الى الجاره بيلاروسيا
وايضا ملف الانتخابات التركيه تفضل
شكرا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات